everybody has to Define their
relationship for themselves like
everyone has a different understanding a
different agreement and you have to do
what works for your particular family
especially when you're both working and
you have busy schedules women are super
women but we also have to recharge our
batteries
and
um I've learned especially in this covet
time to really examine how I'm balancing
my work home life in a different way
that was Nia Long talking about her
relationship with IMEI udoka to ET back
in 2020 now she's speaking out amid
Scandal udoka's alleged infidelity
coming to light and possibly costing him
his job
we have strong values at the Celtics and
we are doing our very best to uphold
them here the NBA is
a central relationship with a female
member of the team's staff breaking the
franchise's code of conduct
and after that presser with Boston
Celtics leadership
udoka issued an apology to ESPN it reads
in part quote I want to apologize to our
players fans the entire Celtics
organization and my family for letting
them down the 45 year old is out for the
entire
2022-2023 season
udoka's statement continues quote I am
sorry for putting the team in this
difficult situation and I accept the
team's decision out of respect for
everyone involved I will have no further
comment
we will make a determination at a later
time about email's future uh with us now
long who has been engaged to udoka for
nearly a decade and shares a 10 year old
son kez with him is speaking out telling
ET in a statement quote the outpouring
of love and support from family friends
and the community during this difficult
time means so much to me I ask that my
privacy be respected as I process the
recent events above all I am a mother
and will continue to focus on my
children long is also Mom to Messiah her
son from a previous relationship prior
to releasing her statement the 51 year
old actress shared this cryptic clip to
Instagram understand one thing as that
light that you see you know you see the
happiness you see The Smiling you see
all the rainbows and all of that stuff
but understand one thing about that
light that they got
they had to go into the darkness to get
it
them people is not the type of people
that you want to play with now we no
long has thoughts about infidelity she's
opened up about the topic to ET in the
past after her Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
co-star Will Smith and his wife Jada
Pinkett Smith shared Jada's now Infamous
entanglement with August Alsina with the
world I think the key to any
relationship is give your partner the
room
to be who he needs to be who she needs
to be and if it means you're taking a
break to do that
take the break
take the break when you know and I think
I feel bad for Will and Jada right now
because they've been extremely extremely
vulnerable with their personal story and
it takes a lot of courage to do that we
all have our ups and downs with love
love is a complicated thing I don't care
who you are former NBA Pro turned to
ESPN commentator Matt Barnes weighed in
on udoka's punishment from the league in
a since deleted video on Instagram
Friday slamming the Celtics for their
decision to suspend the coach
I've been to leave for a lot playing the
league for a long time anyone who played
in League could tell you
this is a very common
situation I've seen it from owners to
Executives to coaches to players to
trainers to therapists to dancers to PR
ladies like
this is not uncommon the Celtics whoever
made this this decision
it was a terrible decision you want to
suspend a man 15 20 25 games
but a whole season for a consensual
situation that not only happens in the
NBA but happens in every single
workplace
this was a terrible call man
uel Barnes seemingly has udoka's back on
this one the vast majority of people on
social media are sharing their support
for long writing that she's a gem who
doesn't deserve to be treated this way
sending her love and light while another
fan summed it all up tweeting that while
they feel bad that her private family
matters are playing out publicly quote
it must feel good to realize you're
universally loved by masses ready to
fight that man for you
[Music]
thank you